هذه بطاقة الهواء في المرة التالية التي
تأكل فيها الأريكة مفاتيحك ، ستساعد بطاقة الهواء في العثور
عليها
باستخدام شبكة العقل الدقيقة حتى
يتمكن iPhone من مساعدتك على تتبع
والعثور على الأشياء الخاصة بك ،
يمكنك تخصيص بطاقة الهواء الخاصة بك
لجعلها خاصة بك حتى مع  من
السهل استخدام emoji airtag بمفرده أو مع
الملحقات الجميلة التي صممناها
حتى تتمكن من إرفاقها
بأي شيء مثل حقيبة الظهر الخاصة بك
أو أي شيء آخر لديك
يمكنك تتبعه مباشرة
في العثور على
تطبيقي  يستخدم اكتشاف دقة الحركة
شريحة u1 الخاصة بنا للحصول على المسافة الدقيقة
لعلامة الهواء الخاصة بك ، حيث يقوم جهاز
iphone بدمج تلك البيانات مع الإدخال من
مقياس تسارع الكاميرا
والجيروسكوب لمنحك ملاحظات لمسية مرئية
ومسموعة ترشدك مباشرةً
إلى بطاقة الهواء
[الموسيقى
] المصممة  لتتبع العناصر وليس
الأشخاص ،
لذلك قمنا بتضمين ميزات الأمان
لتثبيط التتبع غير المرغوب فيه
مثل المعرفات الدوارة للكشف عن العلامات غير المرغوب فيها
والتنبيهات الصوتية من العلامات غير المعروفة.
من المحتمل أن يكون لديك أكثر من
عنصر واحد مهم في حياتك ،
حزمة من أربعة هي 99 طلبًا فقط ،
ابدأ يوم الجمعة ، وستكون بطاقة الهواء
متاحة في 30 أبريل